president-elect Donald won the state of
Texas and there is a Texas elector who
has resigned saying he simply cannot
vote for someone as unqualified as
Donald Trump I'm talking about art
Cisneros who's a member of the electoral
college he's one of the electors that on
December nineteenth was scheduled to
officially say who the next president of
the United States will be and he is
resigned because he says he simply
cannot cast his electoral ballot for
president-elect Donald he told POLITICO
in August that he was thinking about
voting against Trump even if Trump won
the electoral college and a blog post
was published Saturday were Cisneros
wrote that he does not want to be a
quote faithless elector he simply cannot
bring himself to vote for Donald Trump
so he has resigned his role as an
elector and his objections are biblical
in nature to quote from his blog post he
said I do not see how Donald Trump is
biblically qualified to serve in the
office of the presidency of the hundreds
of angry messages that I received not
one is made a convincing case from
Scripture otherwise if Trump is not
qualified and my role both morally and
historically as an elected official is
to vote my conscience then I cannot and
will not vote for Donald Trump for
president I believe voting for Trump
would bring dishonor to God since I
can't in good conscience vote for Donald
Trump and yet have sinfully made a pred
pledged that I would the best option I
see at this time is to resign my
position as an elector this will allow
the remaining body of electors to fill
my vacancy when they convene on December
19 with someone that can vote for Trump
the people will get their vote they will
get their skittles for dinner I will
sleep well at night knowing i neither
gave in to their demands nor cave to my
convictions i will also mourn the loss
of our republic so Cisneros is on the
right path Trump is totally unqualified
to be President of the United States but
the biblical argument is the least
strong one to me although it's
interesting I mean being biblically
unqualified to be President is actually
a relevant pat in a supposedly secular
society that has separation of church
and state right you're not a cardinal
sitting in a room voting for the next
pope right i mean if if you signed up to
do this job i think you should just go
along with the voters had to say really
well candidates to who wouldn't be
biblically qualified and yeah Bernie
Sanders did very well in this election
and he's a Jew well yeah he would not be
biblically qualified according to the
New Testament I guess you would say but
so this is not going to have an impact
right because because this narrows is
leaving and they're going to replace him
with someone was just going to vote
Trump Sisneros should stay in and vote
for someone else at and you could
actually deny an electoral vote to
Donald Trump by letting someone replace
him and vote for Trump he standing up
for nothing other than feeling better
about himself by not casting that vote
for Trump choosing not to vote is still
a decision when you know that you will
be replaced by someone who will vote
Trump his actions do nothing to alter
the path forward of the election and if
his conscience is the issue why not make
a decision why not make a choice that
would actually have a consequence
choosing not to actively decide is you
know in a way not going to change
anything it still has a consequence
right he's opting instead of to deny an
electoral vote to Donald Trump he's
opting to do absolutely nothing other
than her remove his name from the list
of electors he's saying he will do his
task when it's easy or convenient or
pleasurable and when it isn't instead of
actually changing the path he's just
going to allow someone else to do it
it's a more difficult decision to vote
for somebody else he's taking a stand
against actually taking a stand in a way
but the question remains how many other
electors are having these doubts and
might any of them act on it I think
that's an interesting question but
there's another angle here that I want
to talk about Pat which it's it's been
suggested to me that that this could
actually be uh uh something that is out
there to see if other electors will also
express doubts in some way and maybe
some of them wouldn't resign but instead
they would cast a vote for somebody else
maybe Hillary Clinton right because it's
not mandated that you have to go
along with the will of the voters and
there have been faithless electors
before in some cases just because the
people accidentally voted for the vice
president instead of the president now
it could definitely happen yeah I mean
we've heard that there are a Democratic
electors who were lobbying electors who
are Trump electors to change their votes
uh but no word as of now as to whether
anything like that is going on